[Music]
uh dude right before this i was watching
you you saw mr beast went on joe rogan i
don't know if you caught the episode at
all i didn't i just a couple of the
clips where they said like
what do you do with your money and he's
like not much he goes i used to have a
roommate up until recently and we each
split our place for 700 but i got a
fancier place because someone broke into
my house so i needed like some security
but it's still like pretty normal of a
house yeah i didn't see that so i've
only seen one clip and it was basically
the clip of like how did you make it on
youtube
it's a great clip right like it's what's
he saying
so he goes
so he's 23 now and he goes i started
doing this when i was 11.
and joe's like what eleven he's like
yeah he's like i came home and i he's
like i started doing this when i was
eleven and he's like i sucked obviously
at the beginning he's like so he's like
he's like look at me now i don't look
cool now like imagine me at like 12 like
i was like you know pimply you know
pimply face scrawny awkward mumbly kind
of guy and like here i am trying to like
make videos and he's like back then also
youtube really there wasn't a thing like
youtubers wasn't like a thing 12 13
years ago you know so it's like
he's like yeah i just was doing it
because i liked it he goes i hated
school he's i never
in high school i just never even brought
a book home like he's like i remember
doing zero studying my parents got so
mad at me he's like and then like when i
turned
um he's like he's like basically so he's
winning three phases he goes from 11 to
13 i was trying to make videos but i was
like super embarrassed because they were
so bad and joe's like dude are they do
they still exist he goes no i deleted my
channel when i turned 13 because like i
got like i don't know like bullied in
school a little bit i felt embarrassed
so i deleted all those videos but i like
started fresh again at 13 and like
whatever kept going he's like so then
from 13 to like 17 or 18 i was just
trying to make like videos all the time
because my first video
randomly got like 20 000 views he's like
that was the best thing that ever
happened to me i got like this instant
hit and i was hooked and then like it
didn't happen again for a while but like
that first one which was about like
he like hacked some video games like
here here's how they beat this level in
a video game or whatever
he's like some obscure game and it just
like people wanted to know how to do
that hack so that's how i got popular
right away
um or he's like that's how that video
got popular and then i got i wanted to
chase that that that feeling again
so he's like i wasn't making any money
he's like finally i got to the point
where i was making a dollar a day and
he's like yes he's like see i saved up
for like a few months and i bought a
microphone and i was like yeah like now
i sound good like here we go and he's
like i just kept doing that i kept like
making a couple bucks saving it and then
like buy a camera or buy like you know
like a better computer so i could like
edit the videos or screen record or
whatever
and so he just kept doing that for like
six years he's like my whole goal was
that by the time i graduate from high
school
can i like just make enough money doing
this because i don't want to do anything
else
it was not his number
so it did not happen he's like by the
time i he's like by the time i graduated
high school i was making like
400 bucks a month or something like that
and he's like you know it's 300 400
bucks
he's like so my mom gave me this
ultimatum she's like you know you're
moving out or you're like going to
community college like you're not going
to do this video thing
and so he's like oh [__] okay he's like
i didn't want to go to community college
he's like it's like the worst thing in
the world just sitting there listening
to this lecture like that's not what i
wanted to do he's like so i started
skipping he's like every day i would
just go to my car
and instead of going to community
college i'll just edit videos in my car
he's like i do that all day and i come
home and my mom thought i went to school
he's like and he's like that created a
clock
because now she was gonna find out like
by the end of the semester i had zeros
as my grades like she was gonna know
that i did not go to community college
so i had to like i bought myself like
one semester more of time
he's like and in that time i pulled it
off like i got to the point where i
could like self-sustain i just moved out
and then i could like do this like
full-time moving on my own he's like and
so that's kind of like the progression
of how i did it and i was like how
awesome is that how awesome is it
exactly like a bet on yourself story
where
burn the bridge behind you right so so
you know
we say burn the bridges i don't know why
we say that it's burn the boats uh like
if you want to take the island you got
to burn the boats and so he burned the
boats when he when he did that
and uh and knew what he wanted to do
right because like school is great but
school's not for everybody if you
if you kind of know what you want to do
um
you're much better off i think
competing in the free market
on that thing than like competing for
your teachers like love and affection
you know with writing the essay they
want to grade as an a plus right like
writing the thing they want you to write
about in the format they want you to
write
in a way that will get them to give you
the grade right like that's like that's
like not a real market whereas you make
videos on youtube you're competing in
like a real market or you want to be an
athlete yeah it's just that most people
think that they're like going to do
something for life and they aren't
willing to or they don't actually want
to i think i think the the rarity here
is not is someone 18 and capable it's
do they actually love what they're
saying they love enough that they're
willing to dedicate 10 or 20 years to it
right yeah like you know what i mean are
you actually do you actually have a
thing you love
uh most people do not um i remember my
sister when she was going to college my
dad was like all right well like what do
you want to major in she's like i don't
know he's like well what's your favorite
subject like what do you love to study
she's like lunch like you know i just
i'm not i don't have anything against
any of them but like do any of them make
me happy not really so what now what and
like i think that's how most people's
careers go it's like all right well i
don't hate it but i don't love it but
now what what am i supposed to do yeah
yeah yeah so i think that's the rarity
here is that he actually
that he liked something enough um but
anyway that's a good story i'll have to
go and watch this podcast
[Music]
you